I was trying to be cool and liberal and
hate him I couldn't do it dude they
started pumping up George got me going
dude was going through the museum
they're like George Washington was 6'2 I
was like nice
like he could never tell a lie I
was like this guy's
unbelievable like he single-handedly
defeated the British at this point I'm
back on not dude I'm worse I'm ready to
get on Facebook defend written house
whatever I need to do to help this
country get better and then you get to
the end of the tour and the last thing
you see on the George Washington tour is
George Washington's teeth you know the
myth is George Washington had wooden
teeth turns out George Washington had it
was Ivory and Lead Dentures with horse
and cow teeth on the top row and human
slave teeth on the bottom
row Dam what the that's it that's
how the tour ends lead with the teeth
show me the teeth right away dude Don't
Make Me Love George Washington for two
hours and at the very end be like you
want to see some wild